All right.
So look,
I don't want to have one of these talks where I just drone on for some very long
period of time and then there's a question period afterwards.
So please feel free to ask questions,
you know,
during the,
during the talk.
However,
if the question seems to me to be one that's going to involve a long detailed
kind of thing,
I will suggest putting it off till the end.
So I normally talk for an hour,
but I guess an hour is really more or less the time of the whole thing here.
So I'll have to cut stuff out.
Maybe it will be easier to do as I move along.
Um,
okay,
so let me start with this.
So called hard problem of consciousness and that,
uh,
is the problem of why the brain basis of a given experience is the brain basis
of that experience as opposed to another experience or none.
Here's an example.
So,
um,
this is,
uh,
a brain.
The,
all the arrows are pointing to the back of the brain where the early visual
cortex is.
Um,
so there's this area empty and maybe if some surrounding areas like MST that are
known to be the basis of our experience of a certain kind of motion of a optic
flow.
Um,
if you knock that out,
people have a what's called Aiken,
a top CEO where they don't see motion.
Um,
and then nothing gets activated whenever people see,
um,
uh,
when people do see motion,
even if it's after images of motion,
like a waterfall illusion.
Um,
okay.
So we know that as at least a large part of our,
of the neural basis of our experience of motion.
But why is it the neuro basis of that experience of motion rather than say the
experience of a face or something else entirely?
Okay.
So nobody,
it's not just a,
nobody has a clue how to answer that is nobody has even come up with a
hypothetical,
a answer to it.
That is that it all,
is it all satisfactory?
That's why it's the hard problem.
And that's distinguished from,
uh,
the easy problems.
These are my terms,
uh,
produced by my colleague David Chalmers.
Um,
and the easy problems or problems about the function of conscious experience,
um,
how it interacts with a sensory inputs with other mental states like beliefs or
thoughts and how it affects,
um,
uh,
behavioral outputs.
Um,
so those are the so called easy problems.
Now,
um,
a common distinction made,
is uh,
between phenomenal consciousness.
That's what the hard problem is about.
Um,
what it's like just smell a rose,
see the sky,
feel a pain and access consciousness,
which is perhaps can be defined as global availability of the information in an
experience.
Um,
so access consciousness is the domain of the easy problems.
Phenomenal consciousness is the domain of the hard problem.
Now there is,
um,
it is commonly felt and I think that that's,
that that's the feeling I'm talking about.
It is probably present,
uh,
in this room among people who have a kind of engineering way of looking at
things.
Um,
that there really isn't any serious difference between the phenomenal conscious
to an access conscious.
Maybe no difference at all.
Maybe all phenomenal conscious could ever come to is access consciousness or
another thought that is related to that is maybe,
maybe there's a difference in some conceptual way,
but it's not something we could ever find out about because all you know about
anything is how it functions,
how it affects other things.
And we've already said that's the domain of access conscious.
So how could we ever find out about this stuff?
Um,
I used to teach,
I taught at Mit for 25 years and I found that that point of view was a,
was very common among my,
among my students.
It's better for me to do it for me here.
Second.
Um,
okay.
So,
um,
what I'm going to argue,
well,
I'm not really going to argue this,
but I will be saying that,
um,
phenomenal consciousness seems to be better approached through biological
approaches rather than computer approaches.
Computational approaches are,
are better fitted to access consciousness.
Um,
I'm not gonna argue about that explicit,
but what I am going to talk about is how we know these things are different and
I'll give you some actual evidence that they are different.
And say a little bit about how they're different.
Um,
so the issue I'm going to be talking about is our conscious perception and
cognitive access to perception.
That is access consciousness,
fundamentally different talks going to have three parts.
I'll talk about a controversy about sparse versus rich perception about
concepts.
And then I'll,
I'll,
I'll end with these methodological breakthroughs that I think have something to
say about how to approach the issue experimentally.
And I should say by the way that the experimental approach to this subject
really is only about 20 years old.
Before that,
you know,
consciousness research was,
uh,
not a serious thing was regarded as a,
um,
a tenure killer among scientists.
That is if you study it for get tenure.
Um,
okay,
so,
um,
sparse versus rich first.
So there is a debate,
uh,
between,
um,
uh,
the view that a conscious perception is sparse and that conscious perception is
rich.
I myself think that the resolution of the debate,
um,
is that it's cognition that's actually sparse,
that sport reasoning,
problem solving,
um,
and that actual conscious perception is rich.
And that shows that conscious perception must be,
at least in part distinct from cognition.
What suggests that conscious perception is rich here is an experimental
paradigm.
Um,
um,
due to George Sperling,
uh,
so first you have,
I guess I can use this thing.
Can you see that pointer?
Okay,
so you first you have an array of Alpha numeric.
Yup.
Are so rich in your terminology is the machine learning version of it,
which a lot of,
oh here probably,
I'm sure it's different.
Uh,
you will see that,
uh,
it's going to be defined in fact by um,
some experiments I'm going to show you.
But the idea is that cognition,
um,
for certain kinds of materials only holds about four items.
Um,
that is quirky.
It's really what's called working memory.
If you want to,
if you're interested in how people think there is a mental scratch pad known as
working memory.
If you want to,
for example,
go from p and if p then Q two Q,
you've got a store p and if p then Q in your working memory and that holds about
four items.
Now there's a controversy about what exactly an item is.
And there are many controversies about it.
But that's the basic idea.
And it's common to not only,
um,
uh,
mammals,
but also birds,
lizards.
And there's even some evidence that this is rough.
Something like this is the limit even in insects.
So it is a ubiquitous feature of,
um,
of,
you know,
um,
information processing in animals,
uh,
however the number,
so that's sparse.
Okay.
Rich is what's in phenomenal consciousness.
Um,
so that holds many more things.
And that's what I'm gonna Argue.
So it's a way of getting at the fact that they are different.
Okay.
So here is the idea of the,
this experiment.
You show people a,
uh,
an array for a very brief time.
Um,
uh,
and then after the raise bone off,
you ask them what they saw.
People can report that they saw an array of Alpha numeric characters.
Um,
but if you ask them for specific characters,
they can usually report three or four.
Okay?
So there's the limit of three or four.
Um,
so this Guy George Sperling's,
it was in his phd thesis at Nyu,
uh,
um,
tried to explore the idea that people felt that they saw all or almost all of
those items.
And that's,
you know,
it's easy to be a subject in this.
You can do it yourself and you'll have that sense that you saw all or almost
all.
Um,
so what he did was how many new about this,
I'm just curious.
Okay.
No one here has ever taken an intro psych course with my guess.
Um,
okay.
So here's what he did.
He in this blank period before you have to answer,
he used a high tone from the top row,
a medium tones for the middle row and a low tone for the bottom row.
And what he found was they could report three or four from any given row,
even though they could also report only three or four if not given a cue.
And this is called partial report superiority.
And the idea is that your phenomenal awareness ha has a capacity of three times
three and a half,
whereas you can only report three or four.
Okay.
So that is an index of richness.
And here's the spurling,
um,
saying,
uh,
that people insist that they've seen more than they can report afterwards.
Okay.
So that's the kind of thing that suggests rich.
What about what suggests sparse?
So here's a,
a,
undoubtedly everybody's seen one of these things.
You have a picture,
a blank,
another picture that's different from the first one,
and then you start over.
Uh,
this is a paradigm developed by these guys are Reagan Rensin consignments.
And here's an example.
How many see what's changing?
Okay.
I am going to show you what's changing and I hope you'll be surprised.
There it is.
See,
okay.
How many are surprised?
Why are you surprised?
You're surprised because it's a big change,
so,
right.
You know,
it's not exactly in the middle,
but it's a kind of,
it's a big change.
You feel like you saw the whole thing,
but if you did see the whole thing,
why didn't you see the difference?
Um,
I'll show you a couple more here.
Uh,
here's another one.
Yeah.
How many?
See what's changing?
Oh,
it's a little easier this time.
Uh,
okay.
How many,
I mean it's just how many don't see what's changing.
Okay,
good.
Okay.
I'm going to move this pointer to it.
There it is there.
Okay.
I'll do one more just because they're fun.
What's changing?
Is this the,
Ooh,
not doing very well here.
Something's the matter with it.
Uh,
I'm sorry,
somebody was only that.
Okay.
So here is a very pathetic one that I'm going to use this.
You'll see why.
Uh,
so this one is very,
so this was originally made for a PC.
I'm using it on a Mac and I,
you know,
I'm not skilled enough to get it to go faster,
but something is actually changing.
How many see what's changing.
Okay.
I'll tell you what it is.
It's the bar in the back.
See.
Okay.
The reason I'm using that is because I happen to have an eye tracker trace of it
and this gives you a little,
a recipe for making these things.
So the trace only involves one hit on the bar.
Um,
and that is an index of the fact that people are not,
by and large not attending to the bar.
And that tells you what you can change in these pictures.
Um,
and this is a culture relative thing.
It's different cultures will attend and different genders will attend to
different things.
Um,
but if you change something that people tend not to attend to,
then people will not notice the difference.
And that is one of many items of evidence that this is an attentional
phenomenon.
But there are two different accounts of what kind of an attentional phenomenon
is.
One account is this,
uh,
inattentional blindness account,
which is you don't consciously see the features that change.
Okay?
That's the sparse view.
The other view is the inattentional in accessibility.
Um,
or sorry,
lack of access,
not inaccessibility,
lack of actual access.
You do see the features that change,
but you don't conceptualize them at a level that would allow you to notice the
change.
And that difference is going to figure in this whole talk.
The difference between not actually seen it on the one hand a sports view.
And on the other hand,
the rich view,
you see it but you don't conceptualize it at a level.
And here's a little diagram of the difference between the two views and I'm
going to be contrasting.
So this is the top one is my view that you have rich conscious perception.
There's an attentional bottleneck and then you have sparse cognition.
My opponents view,
because they have to explain partial report superiority just as I do their view
is that the bottleneck is between unconscious perception and conscious
perception.
Conscious perception is sparse and cognition is sparse.
So I'm now going to show you a few pieces of anecdotal evidence for my view.
Okay?
Yup.
Quickly,
how would you describe the differences between conscious and unconscious
perception?
Yeah.
Is it an awareness to the information or is it more than that?
Well,
remember I started with the idea of phenomenal conscience.
It's what it's like to smell a rose,
you know,
to hear,
uh,
you know,
um,
of a musical note in conscious perception,
you're having that and an unconscious perception,
you're not having it.
So it's a commonly noted a thing in the literature on consciousness that no one
has a definition of phenomenal consciousness.
It's something you can only point to by using phrases like my colleague Thomas
Nagel phrase,
what it's like to experience experience,
you know,
the redness of red or um,
and of course this not surprisingly has given rise to the idea that when people
set talk this way they don't know what they're talking about and that there
isn't any really any difference between accessing information and having an
experience of the redness of red.
Furthermore,
a lot of people see,
oh,
maybe there is such a thing,
but I don't like it.
So I've encountered that.
You know,
I've gone around and giving talks on this for some time.
I've been cutting a lot and I'm sure there are probably people in this room,
many half the people in this room who don't like phenomenal consciousness.
Why would anybody pay any attention to that?
Um,
but I'll tell you,
I think that it is unwise for people certainly in my business,
but also in yours to ignore such a salient feature of our mental lives because
it may turn out to be really crucial to things you actually do care about.
So I think,
I think people really should keep an open mind about there being phenomenal
consciousness,
what its role is and people should not adopt the view that a lot of people do,
which is that we can approach issues for example in artificial intelligence is
just ignoring this because if it turns out that um,
a lot of our important mental processes are done via um,
um,
uh,
phenomenal consciousness,
then it may be that we,
if we trying to make machine learning,
you know,
machines do significant cognitive things that we're going to have to in some way
give them that or some substitute for it that does the same job or something.
But we'd better know about it before we figure out figure that we don't have to
pay any attention yet
describing it's nice to do,
aren't going to a meeting like the rope memory and was hearing for example like
[inaudible] since it's the same information processing and memories.
All right.
Yep.
Yeah,
I have,
I was
the one who in that's,
that's kind of something that is okay.
I think you could have consciousness without memory.
The reason I'm talking about memory is because it's involved in a lot of
experiments.
So I think it is possible to think about consciousness in the absence of,
without thinking about memory at all.
But um,
you know,
you have to have some experimental approach to consciousness to be thinking
about it in an objective way.
So memory turns out to be really important.
And I'm really contrasting two kinds of memory,
what is sometimes called iconic memory that has some kind of phenomenology to
it,
um,
and working memory,
which is,
uh,
the,
our cognitive workspace.
So,
but that's not because I think memory is crucial to consciousness is because
it's a,
it's a way of getting x or way of approaching the subject that where we know
something about how to do experiments on.
So here is,
so I'm going to,
so just to remind you of what's about to happen,
I'm going to show you two phenomena that I think give a kind of anecdotal
support for my view.
Okay.
So here's the first one.
How many have seen this?
Anybody seen this?
Okay,
this is a slow change.
Uh,
so what you were looking at on the screen is changing right now and your job is
to try to figure out what is changing.
Okay.
Don't say,
okay,
let's,
let's just look at it.
Okay,
let's try to figure out what's changing.
Don't say what's changing.
If you know,
is this a question about this as a vet to say when it's not changing?
Oh No,
don't say that.
How many soul,
what was changing.
Okay.
I'm now going to show you and I think most of you will be surprised.
I'm just going to click on this thing here.
See it?
Everybody see,
okay.
So here's the thing.
Okay,
so here is the intuitive force of this.
I think this argue strongly for my side.
Why do I think that?
Because look at that base.
It's a huge part of the picture.
You were staring at that thing looking around,
moving your eyes around.
You know,
it was on the screen for almost a minute.
And I think,
um,
you must have looked at that thing a few times.
But here's the thing,
why didn't you notice the change?
It's because you didn't conceptualize the color.
You didn't say to yourself at the beginning read.
And at the end purple,
you didn't say the words red or purple.
If you had conceptualized them,
applied your cognition to it,
then you would have been able to notice it.
But it's hard to notice something that you don't conceptualize.
So I think that this suggests that.
Okay,
so this is thing I haven't introduced the global workspace,
so I'll mention that in a minute.
Um,
but,
um,
uh,
the global workspaces and oppose theory of consciousness a opposed to mine.
Um,
and,
uh,
I think,
um,
uh,
I'll,
I'll explain this in a minute,
but I think why I think the,
um,
uh,
the reason that something isn't broadcast global workspaces,
it's not conceptualized.
Now I'm going to show you another one.
How many have seen this?
Oh,
good.
Um,
this is,
well,
I'm not even to tell you what it is,
but just watch and listen to the sound here
precisely for this.
After know
each of you to tell me your whereabouts.
I see the time that they started,
the Dean took place
in the master bedroom.
I was plugging my
arrest
in two years until may is apt to take her away.
Okay.
So now what you're going to see,
you're going to see the whole thing over again from a different camera that
shows you more.
Somebody in this room don't smile at precisely 30,
34 this afternoon was Ruthie.
Tell me your warehouse.
I see the time that it starts in the feet.
Okay.
So here,
this,
by the way,
this is a BB c,
um,
uh,
bicycle safety ad and it's this kind of work that,
for example,
uh,
made people realize that it's really a bad idea to talk on a cell phone while
driving.
Um,
and there's a lot of experimental work that backs that idea up.
And the reason is this is an an attentional problem.
Now my opponents like to think of this as inattentional blindness,
but I think this case argues for my view,
which is intentional lack of access to the difference.
So,
and my reason for thinking that is,
I mean,
look,
for example,
at the,
the guy who speaking you looked right at him.
It really,
uh,
you really must have registered his coat,
for example.
It was one color at the beginning and other color at the end and likewise for
many other things.
So why didn't you notice the difference?
Well,
I think you didn't notice the difference because you didn't conceptualize that
color.
So noticing is a lot easier if you conceptualize,
and I keep using this word concept now I feel like I've used up about half of my
time and I'm really nowhere near done.
Uh,
so this is over it like roughly two.
Is that the idea?
Okay.
Well,
okay,
so look,
I'll have to kind of skip around.
By the way,
if you raise your hand and I don't see you,
it's because the lights are kind of in my eyes,
so you might just wave your hand.
Um,
so,
um,
okay.
So,
um,
well maybe I should start skipping around.
Well,
let me just mention one other experiment.
So this is,
uh,
this is a sort of of spurling like experiment,
done by a group in Amsterdam.
Um,
and um,
the idea is that you have at the start,
you have,
uh,
a a circle of rectangles,
eight rectangles,
and then there's a blank period.
And then there's another circle of rectangles.
And uh,
at some point there's a pointer at points,
at a rectangle and the job of the subject.
And the experiment is to say whether the new,
whether the,
the rectangle pointed to is a different orientation from the first one.
Everybody get that?
Okay?
So the answer in all these is yes,
the point or can come at the end or it can come at the beginning or can come in
the middle.
If it comes.
Um,
uh,
at the beginning people can get almost all eight.
If it comes at the end,
they can get four.
And the idea here is that's the capacity of working memory,
which we talked about before,
the new,
um,
uh,
array at the end,
a wipes out your,
your,
uh,
a phenomenal memory of,
of the array.
Um,
the interesting one is in the middle and here you can get somewhere between
seven and eight.
So the four at the end is an index of your cognitive access or access
consciousness capacity.
The one in the middle is an,
uh,
an index of your,
the,
your phenomenal memory.
So it's these two kinds of memory that are an issue here.
Now,
of course,
my opponents think,
oh,
how do we know that that memory is a conscious memory?
Maybe these things are actually unconscious.
And so,
um,
and then when you get the cue,
there's something has summoned up from,
from unconsciousness.
Um,
so what is clear though is that more items can be held in the,
um,
non-conceptual.
So what I think is that these,
that this memory is,
and what's really crucial to these experiments,
it's a non conceptual memory.
Now,
I think that these non-conceptual,
uh,
representations or are conscious,
but,
uh,
I'll have to wait to get to the evidence for that.
So he,
just to remind you,
here are the,
uh,
um,
of the two views and the put in terms of weather,
uh,
um,
attention.
Um,
it promotes conceptualization is I think,
or whether it is needed for consciousness.
And I should say,
by the way,
um,
which probably people,
something probably people here aren't aware of is which is that,
um,
in recent years,
philosophers have become very tied in with a lot of discussions in um,
uh,
psychology,
neuroscience,
AI.
Um,
and so these people are the disagreements here,
eve equally split between a philosophers and scientists.
Now I've been using this word a concept.
The word concept is actually an ambiguous between,
um,
a sense in which,
it means something that can be shared among many people.
Something kind of abstract that's at the top.
So may meaning like,
or this mental representation sense that was used by the,
for example,
the British in Paris.
So I'm going with the mental representation sense.
It's just a,
I'm just telling you about terminology.
Now,
this notion of a concept is,
um,
often,
uh,
puzzles people.
There's a famous case that helps to illustrate what are,
um,
uh,
on the notion of a concept business.
Uh,
uh,
French philosopher named Bruno Latour who says said that,
um,
Aransas the second could not have died of tuberculosis cause it wasn't
discovered then.
And this is an actual quote before cock,
the Bacillus had no real existence to say that Ramses the second died of
tuberculosis is absurd as saying that he died of machine gun fire.
Um,
and so I quote this part it cause it's kind of funny.
uh,
but the idea here is that,
um,
it's the,
he's confusing the concept in my sense with what it's a concept of.
And so that helps to illustrate the idea of some of my things aren't displaying
properly,
but what can I do?
So what I think is that the,
um,
that the,
that conscious experience is non-conceptual here is one of many experiments that
suggests that this is an experiment done on a 12 month old babies.
And so there's a screen,
they're looking at the screen and object comes out one side,
a different colored object comes out the other side,
then the screen goes down and the,
the babies do not expect two things.
Okay?
So they don't register color.
It's an interesting thing about color and babies,
but,
um,
uh,
their,
their color vision is fine at four to six months.
They can,
um,
uh,
they have all the basic color discriminations.
If anybody's interested in,
I can explain honey,
tell that.
Um,
but,
um,
uh,
they do not use color in reasoning,
between about four to six months and it's starting maybe like 12 to 18 months.
They start using color and reasoning.
So they're non there.
Their appreciation of color is non-conceptual.
Um,
so yeah,
this is what I just said.
Okay.
I am going to have to get,
okay,
so here is a,
a little kind of brain illustration of some of the ideas that are at issue here.
Um,
so,
um,
this is the back of the head where vision starts,
you know,
the light comes in your eyes.
It um,
um,
uh,
is uh,
the signals are sent through threat retina to the,
something in the middle of your brain,
the lateral geniculate nucleus,
and they go to the first cortical visual areas in the back of your head.
Um,
and uh,
the,
my,
my opponents,
so sorry,
these arrows are indicate attention.
This means that the person is attending to the stimulus,
the Arrow pointing to the back of the head where vision starts his attention to
the stimulus.
So this is a,
um,
an a,
a diagram of a brain.
When somebody is uncontroversially conscious of a stimulus,
the person is attending to it.
There are all these,
um,
uh,
reciprocal connections,
reciprocal activations going into frontal cortex.
The key here is frontal cortex.
That's where fought reasoning,
decision making live in the brain.
And my opponents think the people who think all consciousness is access
consciousness,
that it's the,
it's that triggering the activation.
It's called ignition that makes the in,
uh,
um,
and that creates these,
these neural correlations with frontal cortex that are the key to a
consciousness.
Um,
here is a undeniably unconscious perception.
No,
there's something called priming.
If you get stimulus,
it affects your later,
uh,
recognition.
So for example,
um,
if I get,
if I have an unconscious,
subliminal presentation of the word doctor,
I'll be quicker to recognize the word nurse as a word.
Um,
if,
uh,
if I've seen it here is the controversial case,
which my opponent,
Stanislaus,
to hone calls preconscious.
And that is where you have attention away from the stimulus.
You get strong loops in the back of the head,
but no reportability unless attention shifts.
So he thinks that's,
um,
uh,
not conscious.
I say that it's probably conscious.
So I'm now going to move to,
maybe I should just quickly explain the global workspace.
Okay.
So this is a diagram from,
um,
uh,
status lost the home,
um,
who is a French cognitive neuroscientist.
And the idea is that these,
the outer circle is the periphery of your body.
These,
uh,
nodes are our neural systems.
The links are,
uh,
sis are links between neuro systems.
The field didn't ones are active.
Um,
so here's his idea.
The idea is that you have a,
um,
uh,
you have the sensory surface produces a lot of activations there.
It's a competition among them.
Some of them form active coalitions,
and then they trigger ignition into the frontal lobes.
Um,
when the,
when the ignition in the frontal lobes makes the,
um,
uh,
the STIMULII conceptualize.
So I've been talking to a lot about the difference between an conceptualists and
conceptualize.
This is a,
uh,
a,
um,
of a theory of what it is to be conceptualized.
Um,
okay,
so here's the,
I'm just going to quickly get to the methodological breakthroughs and I think
I'll only probably be able to do one of them.
So my two hypothesis here are that conceptualize the stimulus requires global
brigade broadcasting.
This is called global broadcasting.
When these active coalitions trigger representations in the front,
um,
hypothesis two is that non-conceptual conscious percepts do not require a global
broadcasting.
So now a method here that I could use,
okay,
maybe I will do this.
So this requires reddened gleen green glasses,
which I happen to walk with me.
Actually,
there's no time to pass it out.
You know,
I'm going to pass these out anyway and then I can come back to it.
Uh,
so yeah.
Yeah.
So please don't touch the red and the green.
Um,
and then I'd like to have those back at the end.
So until those are all passed out,
which is going to be a while,
I'm just going to,
I'm going to go on.
So if you look at this through red and green glasses,
what years,
what you get,
you get first to face then a house,
then a face,
it fills your whole visual field.
Okay.
It's called binocular rivalry.
Those,
uh,
you have incompatible representations and,
and the,
the processing streams involved in both the two eyes,
Duke it out.
Um,
and interestingly you can,
um,
this is a terrific thing for studying consciousness because you have an
unchanging input with changing conscious percept.
Um,
so,
uh,
and that's a lot of people to identify some areas that are more active when
you're conscious like the fusiform face area of a face and other is that are
active,
more active.
When you're conscious of sale a house,
these things have,
um,
if you ask people to report whether they see a face or a house,
what you get is frontal and parietal links being the key thing here.
And that that has been taken to support the global workspace idea.
Um,
however,
mmm
eye movements can be validated as a measure of consciousness.
So the key here,
this is what's called a,
uh,
no report method.
So here's the problem.
Reports are an index of phenomenal consciousness.
You know,
if you say you saw it,
probably you did see it,
they're also in an exit access consciousness.
How can you use reports to distinguish between phenomenal couch,
an access conscious?
It seems impossible.
People have said it's impossible.
However,
whenever people say something's impossible,
it's a dangerous thing because clever experimenters can find a way to make it
possible.
And that's happened here.
So in an article,
um,
from um,
uh,
Volk Kang,
I now as a group in 2014,
by the way,
I should say that the experiments to the extended,
I'm going to get a chance to go through these experiments are all,
are very recent experiments.
This is an area that is exploding in what people are finding out.
And my approach to the hard problem is,
um,
you know,
nobody can think of an answer to the hard problem.
Um,
but that may be because of the failure of imagination and the way to sort of,
you know,
um,
a juice up your imagination is to figure out how the easy problem works,
how these states affect other states.
And maybe by doing that we'll be able to solve the hard problem anyway.
So when I knows there's lab,
um,
found was that if,
oh,
so does everybody have the uh,
the Renton glasses?
Oh,
whatever happened to them.
oh,
I'm sorry.
What,
what?
They're all distributed.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Well,
okay,
so look,
just going to show you this.
Those
of you have them,
I just want to make sure people see
I'm,
it takes a little while.
So you may,
what you should be seeing if this is working properly is alternating house face
house faced,
unless you have a very,
very dominant eye.
How many are seeing that?
Raise your hand if you're seeing the alternation.
Okay.
Oh good.
I'm sorry I didn't bring enough.
Okay,
so I'm going to go back to this thing.
Okay.
So,
all right.
So if you do the binocular rivalry with a grid moving one way and one eye and a
grid move in the other way,
the other one turns out there's a nice index of what you are conscious of.
And that index is called opto kinetic Nystagmus.
And this is what the eye does.
The eye movements indicate which thing you are conscious of and it can be shown
using people's reports that they correlate pretty well.
But now there's this cool thing.
You've got a re,
uh,
an index of what people are experiencing and know you can show them the original
stimuli and don't ask them to report.
Okay,
no report paradigm.
so here's what is found out.
MMM.
So here's a quotation from the article.
Importantly,
when observers passively experienced rivalry without reporting perceptual
originations,
a different picture that it's a different picture from the global workspace idea
emerged.
Um,
differential neural activity in frontal areas was absent.
Whereas activation in the back of the head and the middle of the head
persistent,
we conclude that frontal areas are associated with active report and
introspection.
Okay?
So contradicting some of these earlier things.
Now I have a lot more on this experiment,
which I'm not going to go into.
Um,
but uh,
you know,
I was very pleased to see this because of course it backs up my view.
What I'm,
as you know,
Eric and I talked to her lunch.
I of course I'm very most,
what I'm most interested in is finding,
you know,
is,
is getting,
uh,
a leg up on the truth,
but have an independent interest in seeing my own views confirmed.
And this did it.
Um,
and quite a lot of these experiments have actually confirmed,
confirm,
uh,
my picture of this,
which I had been pushing for a really long time.
So let me quickly switch to a different one.
So I'm,
there's this longer talk involves three different techniques for avoiding the
probe.
But let me just explain.
The problem I'm trying to avoid,
the problem is both views me,
this is mine,
this is my opponents.
Both of them end up with sparse cognition.
So it seems that the basis of theorizing in reports is going to be the same in
either case.
So that's the puzzle.
And then the one I just showed you is a way around it.
It's called no report.
But of course reports we've got to be in there somewhere in the case.
I just showed you the reports come before the experiment.
The one I'm going to show you now,
the reports come after the experiment and I'll just do this very briefly.
Um,
this uses,
um,
somebody called event related potential,
which is a,
um,
a form of EEG.
And then the idea here is this is my,
my opponent Stanislaus to hon one of my photos.
I'll just,
I won't explain this whole diagram,
but the idea here is this looks at the differences between seen things and
unseen things.
He means consciously scene and not consciously scene.
And you only start to get a separation at about 270 milliseconds to 300
milliseconds.
So you can use temporal differences to get at whether it's a conscious
perception or not on the global workspace point of view.
So here's the technique.
This is work done by Michael Pitts,
um,
at Reed College.
Um,
so the paradigm is this.
You have a ring,
uh,
with these discs in it,
and the task is to detect a disk,
be dimming.
Okay.
And,
and that focuses your attention on the periphery of the screen,
right?
Because it's a very difficult task.
He'd,
he calibrates it to be extremely difficult.
Um,
in the meanwhile,
while the that's going on,
there's constantly changing lines in the middle.
Um,
uh,
so here's a,
an example of a square that occurs in the middle.
Um,
and he's,
he set this up so that only about half the subjects notice it.
So what he does here is the first stage,
which is probably the most significant one,
is he does 240 trials of this dimming detecting thing.
Um,
and then ask people afterwards whether they saw a figure.
and what he finds is that if they,
the,
the heat has a long detailed questionnaire.
He shows him various possible examples of what the figure might've been.
And so he's,
he's trying really hard to rule out guessing and other things.
Um,
so what he finds is that conscious experience correlates with,
uh,
um,
activations earlier than the global workspace at about maybe 200 to 250
milliseconds.
So it's this temporal difference.
So again,
this supports my view and I'll,
I'll just,
uh,
um,
quote some of the what,
what he says here.
I won't show you the whole experiment.
Um,
but here's what he says.
He says,
the pattern results suggest that the neural events reflected in,
and this is this n d one and d two is this stuff right here.
Um,
maybe adequate in themselves to produce visual awareness,
whereas more widespread activity indexed and these things which occurs at 400 to
600 milliseconds,
might be required only when the stimulation need to be processed further to
fulfill the goals of the task at hand.
This dissension parallels that made by previous theorists between phenomenal
consciousness,
an access consciousness.
So this is the first of,
is of many experiments that supports this point of view.
And I won't go into all the details,
but he,
he,
what he shows in the,
in this work is that,
um,
it's reporting,
it's the cognitive processes underlying we porting and,
and conceptualizing that lead to global workspace activation.
And,
uh,
okay.
Um,
so,
um,
so according to this is a 2014 book by one of my opponents,
then it's lost to Hahn who says when the prefrontal cortex does not gain access
to the messenger,
cannot be broadly shared and therefore remains unconscious.
What I think is that that's an conceptualized,
but in many cases conscious.
So just to sum up,
um,
the evidence for rich conscious perception,
uh,
stems from these delayed indicators from eye movements.
And I didn't get a chance to do the ones about just judgments.
And so the idea is that,
uh,
um,
the,
well I haven't really justified this,
but anyway,
do the thought is that,
um,
uh,
phenomenal consciousness probably is not as informational kind of thing as a
access consciousness.
And,
uh,
so I think it's likely to resist a computer approaches and I'm just going to
stop
[inaudible].
So questions.
And they would like you to use the microphone.
Maybe somebody can hand the microphone around.
Sorry.
There was a little quick kind of run through some of the,
some stuff.
Hmm.
Okay.
Thanks.
Um,
I have a question with,
um,
with the trials that you had mentioned.
Um,
I wonder if you see differences or how do I ask this so that the trial seems to
assume that people are always the same,
but like some,
like I'm kinda tired right now,
like it's Monday.
So maybe the way that I would perform with a given trial now if I'm hungry,
if I'm not hungry.
Like how,
how does that,
like the reality of like the body and outside forces influence or not influence
the consciousness trials.
Yeah.
Okay.
So it all experiments,
that's a problem.
There's going to be a lot of variance,
you know,
just treat it as noise really.
It's ways in which the,
you will not get uniformity of response,
uh,
because of variation and all kinds of things to do with people.
Um,
and,
uh,
there's,
you know,
you just have to deal with the noise in the data,
but it is a,
it is a persistent problem.
Hi.
Um,
I wonder back to the title,
uh,
so I wonder y two k summarize why the artificial intelligence approach won't
work for the expansion of consciousness and why.
Yeah.
The thought,
well,
I didn't really get into this.
Uh,
um,
uh,
but the thought behind it is that,
um,
that are,
the artificial intelligence approaches are probably better for access
consciousness then phenomenal consciousness.
This idea of global broadcasting and um,
seems more,
um,
amenable.
You know,
it's information flow basically.
Where's,
what's going on in phenomenal consciousness seems somewhat different from
information flow.
It seems maybe to involve,
you know,
biochemical mechanisms in the brain.
I mean,
we don't know what the nature of fa normal consciousness is.
So I guess maybe what I should really say is there is a possibility that,
um,
information methods based on the flow of information we'll work for phenomenal
consciousness.
It is certainly true that advances to do with phenomenal culture to seem to be
coming from neuroscience rather than from computer science or artificial
intelligence.
You know,
one of the hopes,
I mean,
one of the points that people have made about the global workspace viewpoint,
the one I've been arguing against is that it's in principle implementable on a
machine.
So people who are interested in machine consciousness had been very happy with
the global workspace idea.
So to the extent that I am arguing against the global workspace idea,
I'm arguing against the,
at least the standard kind of computer approach to consciousness.
Your mind,
can we imagine or is a DVD that machines can get consciousness?
Yeah,
I think,
look,
I think we're conscious machines.
So I'm,
you know,
we're meeting machines.
I,
I'm,
I'm not only kind of a dual list or anything like that,
um,
but I think that,
the most obvious application of theoretical approaches to consciousness from a
machine point of view haven't panned out.
Um,
I haven't mentioned really there's a lot of other more machine friendly
approaches.
So,
um,
you know,
some of them may look,
depends what kind of machine,
when we're talking about I,
my feeling is that we may need some kind of analog processes to deal with
consciousness,
but you know,
this is initial stages of a approach to it.
Okay.
So I'm not entirely sure I'd ask this question and it's a very recommend you
buy.
It seemed like a lot of the things you were examining in terms of what
constituted conscious awareness of information or conceptualization of
information in or uh,
you know,
unconscious or preconscious conceptual visionary attraction,
your recognition of information all kind of had to do with a sense that there's
sort of like,
like one place,
like where consciousness is happening,
like catches is all kind of one singular like sort of Cartesian process.
And like if that's not true,
what implication would that have for these questions?
You know,
is it possible that these might all be irrelevant questions to consciousness or
overall?
And I'm really a question of where information and happens to be in the brain at
any given point.
Yeah.
So,
I definitely do not think there is a place in the brain month.
One of my opponents,
Daniel Dennett has used that to caricature my position.
He calls it the Cartesian theater.
Um,
so I think that our best guests about you,
like where are the brain consciousness happens is that every conscious content
is processed by the area that processes that kind of information.
So for example,
um,
conscious,
uh,
contents of motion have to do with uh,
activations in that area empty probably they involve um,
um,
a reciprocal connections to lower visual areas,
conscious,
um,
uh,
appreciation of faces probably has to do with activation and this thing called
the fusiform face area at the bottom of your right temporal lobe.
So I don't think there's any place where they come together.
The closest thing to a place I like to distinguish between what makes a content,
um,
uh,
between the difference between different conscious contents like face and and
motion.
I like to distinguish that question from what makes those contents conscious a
matter.
That has been explored by studying,
for example,
anesthesia.
And it looks like there's some kind of general conductivity,
especially going back to this thing in the middle of the brain called the fellow
amiss.
People used to speak of a thalamic switch.
So the closest thing to like a place where it all happens might be that.
But I don't think that's what explains the difference.
Difference between conscious of a face and consciousness of motion.
It's more like a a,
and you know,
something in the direction of an on off switch.
Thank you.
Hey,
maybe a silly question,
but I noticed all of your example is in this we're done with people.
Yeah.
What about animals?
Like,
yeah.
Okay.
So there a big revolution in the study of consciousness in the mid 1990s when,
um,
uh,
Francis Crick the Nobel Prize winning biologist and Christof Koch realized you
could approach consciousness through studying animals.
And a lot of the work is with animals.
Uh,
you know,
it happened that,
uh,
actually I skipped something that was about needing meant val subjects were
monkeys.
But a lot of the work is in animals.
And,
uh,
I think there's every reason to believe that our primate cousins,
um,
are just as conscious as we are.
Um,
uh,
you know,
it used to be before about 20 years ago that people thought of consciousness in
terms of language.
And I think that access consciousness was,
you know,
what they had in mind.
And I think one of the things that's happened in the last 20 years is people
have realized that language really doesn't have much to do with it.
So yeah,
there's a lot of work on conscious with animals.
Course it's easier to get reports from people.
So,
um,
but there's been really some surprising work with animals where you can really
get at what they,
uh,
um,
you know,
what,
what they're experiencing through nonverbal methods.
Okay.
Thank you.
Hi.
I mean,
if you suppose we had a synapse level simulation at the full human brain,
which I'd argue we might just be 15 years away from her.
So,
um,
with this simulation and exhibit phenomenal consciousness,
uh,
well that's something that people have argued about.
So one common point is that a simulation of a rainstorm isn't wet.
And maybe a simulation of a conscious being isn't conscious either.
So this all goes back to the issue,
which we don't know about,
but which could be true.
That consciousness essentially involves something to do with the neural
processes that are going on brains,
some kind of analog thing.
Um,
and that,
uh,
without an analog devices that sort,
you're not going to get conscious sore example.
Um,
uh,
signals in neurons are electrical,
but the neurons communicate via chemicals that go across the synapse.
Maybe that's part of what's needed for consciousness.
Maybe if you don't have you,
maybe you could make an artificial synapse.
Well,
the people have made artificial synapses,
but you maybe you'd have to use a neurotransmitter's for it to really have
genuine consciousness.
This is the thing,
we don't really know what its most basic level consciousness is.
So we don't know the answer to that
follow up,
uh,
to that,
to not knowing what consciousness is.
Um,
what attempts have been made to attack this question from the point of,
instead of asking what is consciousness asking,
why is consciousness speculating why it evolved even?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
a lot of people have,
have PR have tried to,
you know,
to answer that,
of course it's a little hard to know,
you know,
look,
evolution,
evolutionary reasoning,
you know,
there's,
it's famous for the so called,
you know,
just so stories,
uh,
and to use,
Stephen Jay Gould phrase.
Um,
but there,
there are all sorts of hypotheses,
um,
about,
you know,
why we have consciousness.
It's obviously doing something for us,
you know,
um,
whether,
you know,
here are some possibilities,
maybe it's motivational.
So,
you know,
positive consciousness,
pleasure,
pain.
Maybe it is some,
it's a way of organizing attention or has something to do with interactions with
attention.
Um,
so they're all,
there's no shortage of speculations,
but you know,
it's,
I don't think anybody knows.
Can you describe again the Dra?
I was a bit confused.
The difference between a kind of conscious perception and conscious perception
that is not quite centralized,
which is basically the thing where,
and also once you do that,
discuss a bit kind of the consequences.
Like what,
what would that mean if one theory is towards the,
yeah.
Okay.
So a good,
um,
uh,
index.
So this is the
babies perception of color.
Okay?
So you've got this six month old baby.
It's color discriminations are almost at the level of,
uh,
of an adult.
Um,
and the way you can tell that for example,
is if you have a,
a,
um,
a colored background and a different color disk,
a baby looking at that or,
and an adult looking at that will tend to move their eyes to the disk if they
can see the difference.
So that isn't,
gives you an as one method is a number of methods of finding this out.
That's one method that tells you that baby's distinguished between colors pretty
much the way we do,
uh,
after about six,
four to six months,
however,
they cannot use colors in reasoning.
So here's an example experiment.
Um,
if babies are very interested in movement and noise,
if you,
um,
uh,
and you can,
they can,
so you a display,
this is a done by genre.
Me Hawkman you have a display where I,
wonderful,
noisy puppet thing.
The twirls around.
We'll either occur on the left or the right.
If you see two identical shapes,
then you can set it up so that it's on the left and the baby will notice that
regularity and to unethical shapes look at the left because there's gonna be
something great there.
What about two identical colors on the left?
I can't do it.
They can't,
they don't register colors in a way that allows them to use them in reasoning.
That's what concepts are about.
They're about reasoning and thinking and decision making and evaluating.
They just can't do it.
So,
um,
and in fact,
babies don't even learn the four basic color words until they're three years,
three months old.
Um,
an experiment done by Michael,
but by Mabel rice in the 1980s took kids who did not know that it's between red
and green,
sorry,
do not know the words for red and green and tried to teach them the words red
and green is the three year olds.
She had to go through a thousand trials to get kids to,
to um,
uh,
learn the red green contracts.
The typical thing is once they learn one color word,
they learned them all.
Because you know,
there's,
there's been a lot of experiment to work on this,
but basically what we're dealing with is a creature,
namely the human baby that does not register color in a way that allows them to
conceptualize it.
It's non consumption.
I think all perception is like that.
It's that it's most fundamental level.
It's non-conceptual it,
it,
it sometimes they're automatically conceptualism and it gets into our conceptual
system.
But would you have to realize is the perceptual and the,
and the cognitive or just different in the human brain.
Now maybe that doesn't have to be true in the machine brain,
but you know,
we would be wise to give a thought to how people work when we're thinking about
how to get machines to work.
So that's the,
that's the reason it's relevant
one way or one thing that comes to mind here is maybe another terminology
difference between these two things that might be useful is um,
conceptual is sort of like symbolic reasoning,
symbolic processing,
processing like you would do and like logical formula or something.
Yeah.
Whereas like the other type of processing that you're considering is more like
say it digital signal processor that translates audio data to digital data.
It's not doing symbolic reasoning there.
It's applying just some kind of fixed transformations that seems to be the site
of phenomenal character and your view.
Yeah.
But then gets brought up into this sort of symbolic central unit.
I,
I accept that.
Yeah.
Good.
Are any of these points,
do all of this off?
This makes sense still if you are a dual list.
Ah,
okay.
Yeah.
Um,
I think everything I've said could be accepted by a dualist.
maybe,
uh,
well,
maybe not.
You know,
I did say some things,
it sounded like,
I think there's a neural basis,
but even doulas can accept a neural basis for conscious experience.
So I think everything I said it could
be,
it could be thought of,
could be accepted by a dualist.
So the question is whether that neural basis is really all there is to it or
not.
Okay.
Thank you.
That's,
uh,
that's it for questions and let's thank that again.